let's take a look back at Marvel this
was marvel at one point yeah and now
we're here my how things change
guardians of the galaxy even broke out
the suit of war Comic Con for this [ __ ]
I don't know just seemed the thing to do
so guardians of the galaxy is another
Marvel movie in this already absurdly
successful Marvel phase or phase two of
phased phase there's a lot of phases and
might it doesn't matter this movie
concentrates on star-lord played by
Chris Pratt he's you know he's like the
Han Solo ish character he goes out he
collects stuff he turns it in for money
you know that's his thing he comes
across this artifact that a lot of
baddies want then he becomes a part of a
group of misfits that call themselves
yeah and now we have the movie a movie
that everybody is [ __ ] their pants
over gotta say this movie's a lot of fun
as a fan of Star Trek and Star Wars I
was watching this movie I was like oh
this is what it would look like if the
two combined always wanted to see that
now here it is and now that we know it's
successful the two sides don't have to
war anymore Star Trek Star Wars hug it
out this movie has a lot of things going
for me first of all the ensemble is
great Chris Pratt's really good as
star-lord he is the most fleshed out
character he's the one that they
concentrate on you know him most by the
end of this movie I thought Zoe sultanas
character was cool her backstory is
crazy insanely awesome I feel like you
could have an entire movie revolving
around her backstory and that would be
really cool who knows maybe they'll do
it but as it stands right now I was
looking at her nose like I want to know
more about you than this movie is
actually gonna let me know scene stealer
though actually game stealer movie
stealer rocket he's badass Bradley
Cooper as rocket he stole the show I was
hoping he would I pretty much knew he
would he's one of those guys you walk
out of there the hugest Rocket Raccoon
fan ever if Rocket Raccoon was supposed
to be a kick-ass raccoon with a bunch of
one-liners and really big guns this
movie does injustice he always has
something saying in fact he actually
does it better than star-lord does and
star-lord always has something to say if
the two were in like a roast together
they were in like the mmm eight Mile
battle at the end rocket would win the
star-lord become in a really close
second you'd still love him also they
all make a good team but there were some
wasteful elements to you look at it
you're like that could have been done
better you look at Drax the dude who
plays Drax not the greatest actor the
character of Drax not that flushed out
of me he's on a quest for revenge
against the baddie in this movie because
this guy has really screwed his life up
he says it and that is his motivation
but you don't really you don't
you lit as much as you should I feel
like I would have if the dude was a
better actor also one of the downsides
of this movie I felt was the villain
don't get me wrong the villain was
perfectly functional and you hate his
guts and you're like yeah you need to be
taken down he does some badass stuff
what the problem is you know Thanos is
out there you know he's doing [ __ ] and
you're just like I know at this point
we're taking on number two you want to
power through this guy to get to Thanos
but the fact is we have to deal with
this guy now that shouldn't really hold
that against movie I'm just saying if I
had to compare this guy to another
villain he is like the Dark Elf from
Thor the dark world he's not quite the
next Loki the next Darth Vader the next
crazy awesome villain that you're gonna
remember forever I'm not gonna get the
guy's hot toy I imagine they'll come out
with the hot toys of this guy I'm not
gonna get it because I'm not that
attached to him do I have Loki hell yeah
you bet I do with an ensemble like this
and they haven't had to say their own
movies to build the backstories you just
kind of get all of them their
introduction and them in the thick of it
in this one movie and that it would be
great to know more about them but you're
just not going to just like imagine
watching the movie serenity and not
watching fireflies just you have
serenity still a great time but you're
gonna be left with that I wish I knew
more about those people
I thought the humor really worked in
this movie and then the contrast between
humor and drama was really good it's a
fun here we're a space adventure and
then someone's having a real moment and
then it gets dramatic but in a really
good way in the end guardians of the
galaxy is an absurdly fun ride it's like
if Star Trek met Star Wars met and Mass
Effect met Firefly it's a conglomeration
of a lot of good sci-fi times and you're
gonna have a fun ass time with it some
things could have been flushed out it's
not the perfect movie but am I gonna see
it again I say it again come on you'd
see it again - guardians of the galaxy
is definitely worth buying on blu-ray
there is a post-credits saying I was
hoping the post-credits said yeah at
this point you need to review
post-credit scenes it's kind of weird
but I was hoping the post-credits scene
was gonna be this big thing like holy
boo boo tears Avengers 4 it's not it's
kind of a funny thing it does make me go
are they actually are they gonna do that
or they just joking around right now
either case I laughed and I thought it
was awesome so guardians of the galaxy
have you seen it what did you think
about it whatever you thought comment
below let me know and as always if you
liked what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see more